redondeando 423 1.275 al millar más
cercana y déjame escribirlo de nuevo
423.000 275 y bien pues en lugar del
millar
aquí sería nuestro número tres el cual
queremos redondear lo al millar más
cercano así que tendríamos entonces 420
mil para esta posición pero no déjame
más bien centrarme en la en el millar
que sería nuestro número tres entonces
si quisiéramos redondear lo hacia arriba
entonces tendríamos 424.000 y si lo
redondeamos hacia abajo sería 423.000 no
estaríamos nos estaríamos haciendo del
275 así que ésta sería nuestra decisión
redondear lo hacia arriba al 424 mil o
al 423 mil y para poder decidir esto
simplemente vamos a observar el dígito
que está a la derecha del número 3
el cual nos ayudará a definirlo pues si
te das cuenta este dígito es menor que 5
entonces si fuera mayor lo que haríamos
sería para los números mayores iguales
que 5 en esta posición lo redondeamos al
mayor que sería 424.000 pero en este
caso definitivamente el 2 es menor que 5
entonces vamos a redondear hacia abajo
que será nuestro 423.000 ahora sólo por
visualizar qué significa el millar más
cercano voy a dibujar una línea aquí
abajo para tener una mejor visualización
de esto entonces vamos a dibujar nuestra
línea y coloquemos algunas cifras
tenemos por aquí en nuestra primera
cifra que vendría siendo el 422.000
luego voy a escribir 423.000
luego 424 mil 424 mil y finalmente sólo
por nombrar los 425 mil y ahora hay que
fijarnos donde estaría situado nuestro
423.000 275 el cual se encontraría más o
menos por aquí y si te das cuenta al
decir que lo vamos a redondear al millón
más cercano dicha cifra se encuentra más
cerca al 423 mil y este es para el caso
del millar más cercano si quisiéramos el
más lejano pues sería otra situación por
lo tanto aquí escogemos nuestro 423.000